we do have a special about last night's
opening ceremonies which was held here
in St Louis at the St Louis aquarium
which was a wonderful location by the
way and we had many many many guests all
showing up for the induction and uh well
it was a wonderful it was a wonderful
opening ceremony it was also a wonderful
place to visit of course it's important
place for Saint Louis aquarium right we
could those were the plaques of the new
inductees you see Rochelle and Jennifer
two close friends there
as well
yes getting ready for their speeches
our dear friend Jim and I were roommates
back in the late 70s in Hollywood
California and the legendary Eugenia
Tori gave a very heartfelt speech
thanking everybody
for his induction
and also we had to draw in the floats
and it was conducted with really nice
toys yeah daughters and shirts and
sharks yeah so you can imagine that in
open section they picked up sharks why
did the ladies get the letters
in the open section the Sharks yeah try
to guess what
Ray Ray actually is a super veteran he's
played maybe half his life in these U.S
championships and I'm not joking he's